[Musica]
certo mai visto e come se il castello
fosse scappato da solo dalla mia testa
[Musica]
hai visto berlino forse un cappello
maledetto questi ci sono i portatili
famiglia guardia merini non mi
raccomando aiutami tu che allora una
padella cedere
c'è un fantasma dimmi chi sei che cosa
vuoi da me se nessuno
[Musica]
se qualcuno arriva aiuto
secondo muro dove sei
dove berlino cosa poi vabbè lasciamo in
pace
[Musica]
sei un fantasma
mi è venuta un'idea e il signor fantasma
vieni pure quadro paura
signor fantasma
ora sparisce forse sei tu quello fifone
non io ho io lo aspetto qui finché non
ti fai vedere
e qua
[Musica]
io prego prego per l'impegno è scappato
nel vino
dobbiamo prendendo catturato che almeno
capire cosa vuole da potere sono l'uomo
invisibile se vuoi fermarmi trova in
crediti slime e crea uno slime
invisibile ma come serie a1 slime
invisibile ho paura che questa challenge
sarà un po difficile anche perché non so
dove il nemico non posso mai sapere se
ad esempio adesso mi sta osservando e
ascoltando
vabbè cerchiamo di trovare gli
ingredienti slam il prima possibile e mi
raccomando lasciate un mi piace su
questo video se volete vedere altre
challenge trova gl'ingredienti slime
fosse merlino sa qualcosa
sapete che il mio fedele aiutante in
garino e berlino mi aiuterai anche
questa volta trovato gli ingredienti sta
indicando quale forse qualcosa
vediamo se ha ragione
no non c'è niente merlino forse in
quest'altra alta dell'armadio equa
berlino
vediamo che c'è perché non vuoi che no
prosperino sta richiudendo l'anta
dell'armadio
forse l'uomo invisibile se in ascolto
qua dentro che c'è berlino la mia prime
c'è niente qua la soluzione per melfi
grazie berlino berlino meglio dato a
trovare il primo ingrediente nellino mi
aiuti a trovare anche gli altri
ingredienti berlino sembra più
interessato alle piante che allegri
disney's line da me salute lì troverò da
sola sono un cappellino
vediamo se qualcosa posso di tavolo la
ciotola è stato molto facile per ora
quindi sono sicura che ora di mettere a
quel difficile perché in genere così che
tiene fino a 6 punti simile là dietro
forse qualche ingrediente slime taglia
controllare poi fammi sapere mi
raccomando non ti dimenticare di me hai
capito berlino marlin è salito su a
controllare spero che poi mi faccia
sapere se c'è qualche ingrediente slime
lì a proposito il mio libro è ora
scontato su amazon
quindi se volete prenderlo anche poi vi
lascio il link giù in descrizione ci
sono tantissime ricette
che ci sono anche dei fai da te delle
celle fatemi sapere se lo avete già
perché l'avete preso ma ora continuiamo
la nostra ricerca finora è sempre andare
tutto bene
criticata di prendere la ciotola andiamo
da poterli l'associazione parlanti
ancora qui per fortuna marino e così
quasi tornato dove scappi berlino è
trovato qualcosa che mi sto cercando di
dirmi qualcosa ma non capisco
vabbè continuiamo ad esplorare forse c'è
qualcosa nascosto qua fra i pali
indietro ma per il biglietto ha lasciato
un indizio non me ne sono accorta
vediamo
[Musica]
la paletta sta volando o c'è ruby
sentire
[Musica]
ecco fatto l'ho presa ovunque tu sia
stata super farsene alla figlia luvi
visibile non è così forte come sembra
rica hanno capito ora mi manca solamente
20 carmela ora basta prenderci i tre
punti e li nasconde da qualche parte
tanto sono sicuro che l'uomo invisibile
vuole rubarmi è lì che dite nascondiamo
di ingredienti 4
ecco ora dobbiamo trovare il bicarbonato
e la colla e poi forse riusciamo a
vincere la challenge se riesco a capire
come fare lo stein invisibile però i
miei amici miei a trovare la colla e
bicarbonato
ma perché è mobilitare in questo
challenge berlino con troviamo social
dinamo non mi sembra che ci sia un bel
niente sotto il divano
non so perché ma marino che i rumori
strani comunque merlino in questa
challenge non pole per aiutarli
non capisco il motivo ma c'è un po la
collera qui incastrata
proprio qui nel divano e una colla verde
ai mi sono dimenticato di dirvi se non
mi seguite ancora su instagram
seguite il nome ovviamente anita stories
mi aspetto anche solamente bicarbonato
per voi che ha controllato ovunque non
c'è da nessuna parte se chiti si aiuta
l'uomo invisibile
lo so che lui in teoria non dovrebbe
collaborare con me ma
[Musica]
sentite anche voi questo rumore che come
se qualcuno stesse dormendo va vicino
mettiamo a controllare non ridono senti
anche tu
qualcuno è stato il meglio sul divano
[Musica]
contro gli occhi torniamo una coperta
ma c'è qualcosa di strano
[Musica]
che strano c'era proprio qualcosa qui
era stata una coperta
lo fa o guidarmi bicarbonato per favore
e va bene farò finta di niente
farò finta che non esiste
[Musica]
ripresa se vogliamo che lo come mister
meno ruby nuovamente abbiamo tutto qua
ti preghiamo si sa fare lo slime anche
se non so come farlo andiamo a mettere
la colla finita ok non è tantissimo ma
non se ne uscirà lo stesso mettiamo
pochissima soluzione per l'antico e
pochi scrivo bicarbonato proprio perché
c'è pochissima cosa così può costare
andiamo mischiarlo eccolo qua lo slime è
pronto ora devo capire come fare a farlo
diventare invisibile non ha niente di
speciale questo slime è solo uno slam
perde perché non ci ha pensato lo sa in
green screen è come se fosse uno fra
invisibili lo slide green screen quindi
troviamo subito da applicare in green
screen e vediamo se funziona 3 2 1 a
monserrato fai da te ha funzionato è
diventata invisibile
quindi vuol dire che ho vinto la
challenge che cosa dovrò fare adesso
forse lo moltissimi tir a qualcosa come
visibile
ho fatto le strenne invisibile come mi
avevi chiesto guarda eccolo qua come
visibile
penso di aver vinto la challenge dove
sei adesso starà forse prendendo in giro
un altro foglietto hai vinto quindi ti
lascerò in pace
ma se questo video raggiungerà i 45 mila
mi piace svelerò la mia identità
wow sono proprio curiosa di vedere chi
sei uomo invisibile ora sparissi pure
così almeno mi puoi lasciare in pace il
passato ben di pièces questa sala e
soprattutto se volete rivedere l'uomo
invisibile
però adesso quattro cartellini e se
pubblicare per vedere i miei altri video
cliccati su quello che preferite e buona
visione
ciao
[Musica]